the stark realities that we have only
five days left to find the ultimate
agreement until now I have avoided
talking about deadlines but tonight I
have to say it's loud and clear that the
final deadline and this week
we have egg waxes in area prepared in
detail we have a scenario as far as
humanitarian aid is concern
we are like medicine for diabetes or
dementia for heart disease some vaccines
and the main reason is that there is a
liquidity problem and we can't pay for
it our suppliers
we charge per character to lead out a
surrogate on the Anita River she was for
all significant 23 national phonetic in
big game license of them does the after
show me
Greece is broke and owes European
governments and banks hundreds of
billions of dollars